well welcome welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina the ship's
to your house house well let me ask you
this you like jokes right
I love joke okay so I wanted to read
some jokes to you and talk and you tell
me what you think of these jokes okay
how can you tell when a blonde sends you
a fax ah I love blonde jokes by the way
I don't know it has a stamp on it I love
it
I love those jokes oh we got a little
project ok how can you tell if a blonde
has been using your computer I don't
know there's white out all over the
monitor oh I got one for you too okay go
go ahead go ahead
okay this lot is sitting at a bar in
Chicago watching this yeah the one of
these bars where they had the TV behind
the bar and there's some guy up on the
ledge getting ready to jump so this this
guy sits down next to her and he says to
her this is the the six o'clock news and
he says I bet you he jumps in the blonde
says I bet you drink he doesn't and all
of a sudden the guy jumps and so the
guy's the blonde says I guess I owe you
20 dollars and he said no I really can't
take the money because I saw it on the
five o'clock news in the blonde says so
did I but I thought you might change his
mind
I think that's hilarious
my god just think that so funny you
imagine yeah man that's funny uh how do
you draw how do you drown a blonde uh
you know have her stand in the shower
for a long time
no I don't know I'm just guessing I
don't know okay you just go how you put
a scratch-and-sniff sticker at the
bottom of the pool that's funny that's
funny
all right good what did the blonde say
when she saw the sign in front of the
YMCA I don't know
look they spelled Macy's wrong funny
yeah I got one more blonde joke for it
oh yeah yeah yeah please keep it coming
okay so this blonde she was going to go
from New York to Europe to London yeah
so she just climbed on board and she
said in first class without a
first-class ticket and the steward says
I'm sorry miss but you're not allowed
you have to go back into coach
she says I'm blonde I'm beautiful and
I'm going to London in first-class
well the stewardess never had anybody
talk to her like that so she went to get
the copilot Koba came out as Miss he got
to go to the back of the coach with
everybody else you don't have
first-class ticket she goes I'm blonde
I'm beautiful and very busty as you can
see I'm going to London in first-class
well we call pilot he didn't know what
to do so he goes up and tells the
captain the captain says don't worry
I speak blond captain goes back whispers
some interior she pops up and runs back
into coach and the other said what did
you say to her I told her that only
coach is going to London
fact that again Solaris yeah it's good
some broad can you imagine us to figure
out take the airplane got a surprise
yourself here I mean odd dumb kitty yep
yeah really funny actually I love that
joke that's a good guys I just took
sometimes I just tell jokes to myself to
make myself laugh oh god really oh yeah
yeah seriously yeah oh yeah yeah I'm man
that's a lot of I can see abroad doing
that though you know I could yeah the
other kind of jokes are like I like I
like Polish jokes yeah who does yes
you're right these two pole locks are
driving down from Cincinnati them to
Miami around I 75 75 they saw sign it
says clean restrooms hip yeah
so the time we got to Miami they cleaned
150 it's funny that's good there is good
yes hey you know what the work you know
what the world's shortest book is what
polish war hero
yep time Gary insurrections why do why
do blondes wear panties I have no idea
to keep their ankles warm oh yes wow
yeah yeah I love this I love my jokes
hey where do you look for for blondes
obituaries ah in the sports page no
under home improvements that's good
that's really funny good hmm
who plays pretty good man yeah you know
it's it's you know if you know it's you
don't do many one-liners like this but
this is get some good stuff your buddy I
love you know I'm kinda trying to think
some other blonde jokes you caught me
off guard here but remember one time i
just like google blonde jokes it works
yeah I must let do 20 or 30 FM so you
think I should do these you guys I start
doing it on stage no I actually I think
you're much better doing what you do
really and yo yeah because you tell a
story you captivate okay you know the
trouble with the block was with a short
joke is jokes over
you know you know yeah yeah you know
will you do the stories like you do it
just the sense of anticipation you know
it's like jumping out of an airplane you
know with no parachute let me tell you
some of some other ones I've been
thinking up okay how do you sink a
Polish battleship uh you could just say
how you don't have to actually try to
answer that just a joke I have no idea
yeah
you put it in water you know what you
know what how are you bearing at with me
see how this one goes
yeah you know what you know what these
two poet these two Pollock have decided
to bury their father at sea yeah he was
just and they both drowned ate his grave
that's good that's good
why does the why does the Pollock cross
the road cuz they want to get to the
other side no he couldn't get his dick
out of the chicken oh yes well I'm glad
you really enjoyed it and now I know how
to cheer you up if you're ever in a bad
mood Jesus all I have to do I've never
really in a bad mood well that's true
that's true I just you know all I have
to do to entertain myself actually is
think about all your childhood
experiences with me Oh
dad let me I got you one more here how
do you know if you're in front of a
Polish firing squad the remotely guns
are faith
at the head I said hey dad do you not
understand how these books work you're
not supposed to actually try to answer
them it's that's it's just setup Python
okay I give up
are you okay well yeah you know you're
standing in front of a polish fires but
they are standing in a circle yeah I
heard that wonderful yeah that's funny
what actually yes hmm that's a what oh
yeah that is funny yeah who how do you
get a Polack out of a bathtub I don't
know you throw in a bar of soap okay
what do pole locks use Cheerios for dad
what do Pollock use Cheerios for I don't
know donut seeds donut seeds oh my gosh
I love it
try leave I think I got a good one for
you it's an Olympic thing yeah what do
pole locks do with all their gold medals
they don't have any no what like again
like again it's just set up a joke I
don't know okay they go home and get
them bronzed that's funny yeah oh yes
this is one of the best conversations of
my life oh I love just laughing Tommy I
know dad this it's an ideal enjoyed it
um alright I'll give you a call here in
a little bit okay I got a run for a
milky buddy buddy let me get my man oh
yeah wow that was possibly one of the
funniest calls we've ever had with him